okay we want to simplify this complex
fraction it's a fraction within a
fraction and so the way that we do that
is two different methods one method is
where you try to combine the numerator
into one fraction we try to combine the
denominator into one fraction when you
divide by a fraction it's like
multiplying by the reciprocal and then
you can simplify from there
the other method that we're going to do
method number two is we're going to
clear the denominators by multiplying
the numerator and the denominator by the
common denominator of all the fractions
to clear those denominators and then
that eliminates the complex fraction so
method number one let's see if we can
combine these fractions together so we
can just have one fraction in the
denominator the first thing I would do
is I would factor this x squared minus 4
into X plus 2 X minus 2 okay so I'm just
rewriting it in order to get common
denominators here this is X plus 2 it's
missing an X minus 2 so let's multiply
the numerator and denominator by X minus
2
so now what we're left with is the
numerator stayed the same it's 3 over X
minus 2 okay that's this group here but
the denominator we have 4x minus 8 minus
2 X all divided by the common
denominator X plus 2 X minus 2 okay so
you can see now we just have a fraction
divided by a fraction but when you
divide by a fraction it's like
multiplying by the reciprocal so you
keep the numerator the same but you're
going to multiply by the reciprocal of
this denominator here so it's going to
be X plus 2 X minus 2 and then this is
going to be 4x minus 2x which is 2x
minus 8 okay I just simplified that
numerator but we're multiplied by the
reciprocal now what we have is we just
cross that out you can see that the X
minus 2's are going to cancel numerator
and denominator and we're just left with
3 times X plus 2 all over 2 I'm going to
factor this times X minus 4 and the
reason I factored it is because
sometimes you get some cancellation on
numerator and denominator so it's good
to keep it factored and see if you can
reduce so this is our final result now
let me show you method number two so
method number two you would say okay
let's look at all the denominators we
have an X minus 2 here we have an we had
an X plus 2 right and here we had an X
plus 2 and X minus 2 so what we would do
is we'd multiply through by the common
denominator let me start by rewriting it
so we can see a little bit clearer so we
have 3 over X minus 2 and we have 4 over
X plus 2 and we have 2x over X plus 2 X
minus 2 but what we're gonna do is we're
going to multiply by X plus 2 X minus 2
to the numerator and the denominator so
anything divided by itself is 1 so when
you multiply by 1 it's not going to
change this fraction it's just gonna
change the way that it looks so when we
distribute this here notice how the X
minus 2's cancel so we just have 3 times
X plus 2 in the denominator here when we
take this and we distribute it this
group to the first fraction you can see
that X plus 2's are going to cancel so
you're just going to have 4 times X
minus 2 when you distribute this to the
second fraction what happens is that X
plus 2 X minus 2 cancel and you're just
left with the 2x so if we simplify this
down a little bit we have 3 times X plus
2 here we have 4x minus 8 minus 2x which
just gives us 2x minus 8 and then we can
factor that denominator again like we
did before and you can see we're getting
the exact same and result so either
clear the denominators by multiplying
through by the common denominator or
combine your fractions in the numerator
to get one fraction and the denominators
to get one fraction and then multiply by
the reciprocal of the denominator so
that you get rid of the complex fraction
if you want to see another example check
out the video I did right there I'll see
you over in that video